Wie immer wird es im KI-Bereich nie
langweilig, denn es gibt ein paar neue
große Geschichten, über die wir
sprechen können. Beginnen wir mit
Anthropic, dem neuen Claude Sonnet 5.5,
das schon sehr bald erscheinen könnte.
Das basiert auf den gestrigen Leaks, in
denen wir darüber sprachen, dass
Anthropic dieses Modell anscheinend
noch testet. Aber heute haben wir
tatsächlich die ersten Vorschauen
darauf, was es kann. Und ehrlich gesagt
sieht es so aus, als würde Anthropic
die Sonnet-Reihe in großem Stil
wiederbeleben. Wenn das Modell zu den
vorgeschlagenen Preisen und mit der
vorgeschlagenen Effizienz auf den Markt
kommt, die ich später noch enthüllen
werde, könnte Sonnet 5.5 ein
ernstzunehmender Konkurrent für GPT-6
Sole werden, vor allem wenn man sich
diese frühen Vorschauen ansieht. Und
meiner Meinung nach sieht es bisher
viel besser aus als GPT-6 Sole. Das
führt uns zu OpenAI, denn Berichten
zufolge bereiten sie ein neues,
höherwertiges ChatGPT-Abonnement
namens ChatGPT Pro Max vor, das
möglicherweise zu einem verrückten
Preis von 500 US-Dollar pro Monat
erhältlich sein könnte. Bislang
gehören Hinweise auf die schnellste
Arbeit mit Codex zu den größten
festgestellten Unterschieden im
Vergleich zum regulären Pro-Modell. Es
gibt Spekulationen, dass die
Infrastruktur von Cerebrus die Lösung
antreiben könnte, zusammen mit
potenziell höheren
Nutzungsbeschränkungen. Und natürlich
werden wir aufschlüsseln, was Sie mit
diesem neuen Plan tatsächlich erhalten
könnten. Apropos OpenAI: Erinnern Sie
sich an Bell? Nun, es gibt eine weitere
wichtige Entwicklung im Zusammenhang
mit den internen KI-Fähigkeiten von
OpenAI. Laut OpenAI hat das Training
dieses neuen internen Modells am 28.
August begonnen und es hat inzwischen
mehr als 100 seit Langem offene
mathematische Probleme gelöst,
zusammen mit dem behaupteten Durchbruch
bei Navier-Stokes. Seine Fortschritte
haben die Mathematiker bei OpenAI
offenbar so überrascht, dass das
Unternehmen nun mit einer unabhängigen
mathematischen Beratungsgruppe
zusammenarbeitet, um diese
KI-generierten Entdeckungen zu
überprüfen und zu kommunizieren.
Kommen wir nun zu Google: Die haben
gerade etwas Verrücktes angekündigt.
Das Projekt Sun Catcher ist ein
Moonshot, bei dem es darum geht, die
Integration von KI-Berechnungen in den
Weltraum zu erforschen. Hier bereitet
sich Google darauf vor, TPUs in eine
niedrige Erdumlaufbahn zu schicken, um
zu prüfen, ob der Weltraum
tatsächlich eine riesige
KI-Infrastruktur beherbergen könnte.
Satelliten könnten die nahezu
konstante Sonneneinstrahlung nutzen,
während TPU-Cluster über
Laserverbindungen mit hoher Bandbreite
kommunizieren. Google hat seine Chips
bereits unter extremen Vibrationen,
Strahlung und Vakuumbedingungen
getestet. Der erste TPU-Test im Orbit
steht noch vor zwei größeren
Satellitenexperimenten im Jahr 2027 an.
Und schließlich gibt es eine neue
Möglichkeit, Claude Opus 5.5 auch nach
Erreichen der Ratenlimits weiter zu
verwenden. Sie ist langsamer und
funktioniert nur, wenn zusätzliche
Kapazität verfügbar ist, könnte Opus
5.5 aber deutlich benutzerfreundlicher
machen. Ich zeige dir, wie du damit
loslegst, und gebe dir ein paar Tipps
und Tricks, die dir helfen werden, Opus
5.5 besser zu nutzen. Natürlich gibt
es noch viel mehr zu besprechen, also
lass uns einfach alles kurz und knapp
zusammenfassen. Dein KI-Agent kann eine
ganze App schreiben, aber wenn du ihn
bittest, Live-Daten abzurufen, musst du
plötzlich mit API-Schlüsseln, Konten
und Abonnements jonglieren. Hier kommt
der heutige Sponsor Monad ins Spiel.
Denk an Openrouter, aber für
Agenten-Tools. Mit nur einem Schlüssel
erhalten Sie Zugriff auf über 2.000
Tools. Web Scraping, Anreicherung, SEO
und Social-Media-Daten. Geben wir
Claude eine echte Aufgabe. Er ruft mit
Monad die aktuelle Preisseite von
Perplexity ab und vergleicht die
einzelnen Pläne. Claude wählt das
Tool aus und tätigt den Aufruf über
Monad. Das Tool gibt die Seitendaten
direkt an die Konversation zurück. Der
Bot wandelt diese echten Daten dann in
einen übersichtlichen Vergleich um und
enthält einen Link zurück zur
Preisseite. Sie zahlen pro Tool-Aufruf
über ein einziges Guthaben, ohne dass
separate Anbieterkonten oder
Abonnements erforderlich sind. Bei
jeder Anmeldung erhalten Sie
automatisch 1 $ Gratisguthaben, ohne
dass eine Karte erforderlich ist.
Schauen Sie sich Monad also über die
Links in der Beschreibung unten oder
den angehefteten Kommentar an und
verbringen Sie weniger Zeit mit dem
Einrichten von APIs. Vielen Dank an
Monad für das Sponsoring des heutigen
Videos. Beginnen wir mit dem, worüber
wir gestern gesprochen haben, denn
Anthropic führt derzeit einen
Stealth-Test von Claude Sonnet 5.5
durch, das unter dem Modell-Slug
Claude-Sonnet-5-5 entdeckt wurde. Und
bisher haben wir einiges über dieses
Modell erfahren. Offenbar erhielten
ausgewählte Partner nur 24 Stunden
Zugriff und die Nutzung des ersten
Tools wurde inzwischen eingestellt.
Sonnet 5.5 soll außerdem mit einem
riesigen Kontextfenster von 1 Million
Token und bis zu 128.000 Output-Token
ausgestattet sein. Das Denken ist
standardmäßig adaptiv, während
deaktiviertes Denken offenbar nur für
niedrigen, mittleren und hohen Aufwand
verfügbar ist, nicht für XI oder Max.
Was mir aber wirklich auffiel, und das
hatten wir gestern bereits besprochen,
ist der gemunkelte Preis: 2 US-Dollar
für 1 Million Input-Token, 10
US-Dollar für 1 Million Output-Token
und nur 20 Cent für 1 Million Token
pro Cash-Rate. Wenn diese Zahlen
tatsächlich stimmen, könnte Sonnet
5.5 ein unglaubliches Wettbewerbsmodell
sein, das mit GPT-6 Soul auf Augenhöhe
sein wird und vielleicht sogar besser,
wenn man sich einige dieser neuen Leaks
ansieht. Wir wissen natürlich bereits,
dass Sonnet 5.5 kommen wird. Wir haben
es gestern in unserem Video erwähnt,
aber heute haben wir endlich unsere
ersten Vorschauen auf Sonic 5.5
bekommen. Und diese Vorschauen sind
bisher der Wahnsinn, was die
Möglichkeiten angeht. Wie in
verschiedenen Voxel-Art-Generationen
kann man sehen, dass Sonic 5.5 dem
gerade erst erschienenen GPT-6 Soul
ernsthaft Konkurrenz macht. Und meiner
Meinung nach sind der kreative Touch
und die Elemente, die Sonic 5.5
hinzufügen kann, einfach der Wahnsinn.
Und bei diesem Preis glaube ich
wirklich, dass es ein riesiges Upgrade
gegenüber GPT-6 Soul sein wird. Das
ist nur meine Meinung und meine
Vorhersage. Ich sage nicht, dass das
passieren wird, aber basierend auf dem,
was ich bisher gesehen habe, tendiere
ich dazu, Sonic 5.5 gegenüber GPT-6
Soul zu verwenden. In 3JS wurde
angefordert, ein Schloss zu erstellen,
und dies ist eines der Ergebnisse, die
es generiert hat. Nichts Verrücktes
oder so, aber dennoch eine ziemlich
gute Generierung, die ordentlich
Texturen und Elemente hinzufügt. Diese
beiden Controller wurden beide von der
Cloud Sonic 5.5 generiert, und das
Ganze wurde mit X-High Reasoning
durchgeführt, und ihr könnt die
Qualität hier sehen. Und das sind zwei
Controller, die in SVG codiert wurden,
und der Detailgrad ist ziemlich
verrückt, denn ihr könnt sehen, dass
die Texturen der Tasten vollständig in
SVG-Code codiert wurden, mit der
richtigen Beleuchtung und den Shadern,
die dieser SVG-Generierung
zugeschrieben werden, was für sich
genommen schon ziemlich einzigartig ist
. Ihr könnt sehen, dass der
Xbox-Controller wirklich genau
generiert werden konnte, aber was den
PS5-Controller angeht, sage ich nicht,
dass er nicht genau ist, aber er sieht
nicht unbedingt genau wie ein PS5-
Controller aus. Nichtsdestotrotz wurden
alle Elemente eines PS5-Controllers
hinzugefügt, und insgesamt hat er
trotzdem einen ziemlich guten Job
gemacht. Wenn ihr die besten KI-Tools,
Workflows und Drops vor allen anderen
haben wollt, dann abonniert meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter mit dem Link in
der Beschreibung unten, der völlig
kostenlos ist. Hier ist nun der von
Sonic 5.5 generierte Minecraft-Klon und
ich muss sagen, die Texturen und alles,
was generiert wurde, weisen ähnliche
Eigenschaften wie das ursprüngliche
Minecraft-Sandbox-Spiel auf, wie zum
Beispiel die Blumen. Ihr habt sogar die
Möglichkeit, die verschiedenen Mobs
anzugreifen. Es hat sich wirklich Mühe
gegeben, diese Mobs mit anständigen
Texturen zu erstellen, und sie sehen
insgesamt ziemlich gut aus. Wenn ihr
die Schafe tötet, bekommt ihr auch
Wolle, was ganz nett ist. Es hat zwar
keine außergewöhnlichen Animationen
hinzugefügt, wie zum Beispiel die
Animationen, wenn ihr Blöcke zerbricht
, aber egal, wenn ihr verschiedene
Arten von Blättern zerbricht, seht ihr
, dass ich einen Stock habe, was
ziemlich einzigartig ist. Es gibt ein
Crafting-System und ich glaube, es gibt
Höhlensysteme, die ich finden müsste,
und die habe ich gerade hier drüben
gefunden. Es gibt Erze und wenn ihr
fallt, erhaltet ihr auch die
Schadensanimation. Aber lasst uns
tatsächlich nach oben gehen, denn
diese Höhlen sehen nicht so schön aus
. Mach das mal. Mal sehen, wie tief wir
gehen können. Insgesamt sieht es
ziemlich gut aus. Ich denke, das ist
Schotter. Ja, das ist es. Und die
Generationen wurden ganz gut umgesetzt.
Sogar die Physik, bei der man den
Schotterblock platzieren kann und er
sofort herunterfällt, wie im
Originalspiel. Das ist wirklich
ziemlich cool. Es gibt sogar eine
Hungerleiste und dann gibt es noch das
Crafting-System. In Zukunft scheint
OpenAI tatsächlich einen brandneuen,
höherwertigen ChatGPT-Tarif auf den
Markt zu bringen, der sich ChatGPT Pro
Max nennt. Und dieses Ding könnte
lächerliche 500 US-Dollar pro Monat
kosten. Wir haben tatsächlich schon
einmal auf dem Kanal darüber
gesprochen, dass OpenAI ein viel
teureres Abonnement in Erwägung ziehen
würde, das Berichten zufolge bis zu
2.000 US-Dollar pro Monat kosten soll.
Ich schätze, jemand hat ihnen endlich
zur Vernunft verholfen und den Preis
auf 500 US-Dollar gesenkt, was immer
noch absolut verrückt ist. Aber der
Plan wurde jetzt in der Entwicklung mit
dem schnellsten Arbeits-und Codex-Tag
entdeckt und befindet sich derzeit in
einigen verschiedenen Katalogen einiger
Benutzer. Der einzige Unterschied zum
regulären Pro-Tarif besteht darin,
dass dieser auf der
Cerebrus-Infrastruktur basiert. Das ist
zwar noch nicht zu 100%bestätigt, aber
die Leute haben das bereits gesehen. Es
bietet den Nutzern möglicherweise eine
viel schnellere Leistung und höhere
Nutzungslimits. OpenAI hat auch daran
gearbeitet, ChatGPT die Verarbeitung
von Aufgaben mit viel längerer
Laufzeit zu ermöglichen. ProMax
könnte also möglicherweise auch in
diese Richtung gehen. Und da der OpenAI
DevDay vor der Tür steht, müssen wir
möglicherweise nicht mehr lange warten
, um zu erfahren, was dieser Plan für
Sie bereithält. Erinnern Sie sich noch
daran, wie wir über OpenAIs
mysteriöses internes Modell Bell
gesprochen haben? Nun, wir haben einige
ziemlich verrückte neue Informationen
über OpenAIs interne KI-Fortschritte
in der Mathematik. Laut OpenAI hat ein
internes Modell am 28. August mit dem
Testen und Trainieren begonnen. Dies
ist wahrscheinlich eine der
Belastungsproben des Bell-Checkpoints.
Berichten zufolge löst es nun mehr als
100 langjährige mathematische
OpenAI-Probleme in verschiedenen
Bereichen der Mathematik selbst,
zusätzlich zu seiner behaupteten
Lösung des
Navier-Stokes-Millenniums-Preis-Problems
. Und anscheinend hat die
Geschwindigkeit des Fortschritts sogar
Mathematiker innerhalb von OpenAI
überrascht. Aus diesem Grund arbeitet
OpenAI jetzt mit einer neuen
unabhängigen Beratergruppe von
Mathematikern zusammen, zu der einige
äußerst angesehene Namen gehören,
darunter Timothy Gowers, Martin Hairer
sowie Ravi Vakil und Edward Witten.
Ihre Aufgabe besteht im Wesentlichen
darin, bei der Beurteilung zu helfen,
wie bedeutsam diese KI-generierten
mathematischen Ergebnisse tatsächlich
sind und wie sie der Öffentlichkeit
und der Forschungsgemeinschaft
kommuniziert werden sollten, und wie
akademische Standards aufrechterhalten
werden sollten, wenn KI beginnt,
direkter zur mathematischen Forschung
beizutragen. Und nur um das
klarzustellen: OpenAI hat nicht
öffentlich gesagt, dass es sich bei
diesem internen Modell um Bel handelt,
aber wenn man bedenkt, was wir bisher
über Bel gehört haben und wie genau
das hier ablief, sieht es definitiv
danach aus, als wäre es der
Bel-Checkpoint. Wenn dir dieses Video
gefällt und du den Kanal unterstützen
möchtest, kannst du über die Option
„Super Thanks“ unten für meinen
Kanal spenden. Oder du schließt dich
unserem privaten Discord an, wo du
monatlich kostenlos auf mehrere
Abonnements für verschiedene KI-Tools
zugreifen kannst, sowie tägliche
KI-News und exklusive Inhalte und
vieles mehr. Kommen wir nun zur
Hauptstory des heutigen Videos, denn
Google schickt seine KI-Chips
buchstäblich ins All. Ja, im Ernst,
denn Google hat ein wichtiges Update
für das Projekt Sun Catcher
veröffentlicht, sein Moonshot, um zu
erforschen, ob wir letztendlich eine
riesige KI-Recheninfrastruktur im
Weltraum aufbauen können, ähnlich wie
Elon es sich vorgestellt hatte. Google
bereitet sich jedoch darauf vor, einen
Prototyp-Satelliten zu starten, der
seine TPUs in eine niedrige
Erdumlaufbahn bringt, um zu sehen, wie
sie sich im Weltraum tatsächlich
verhalten. Das ist ein wichtiger Grund,
warum Google an diesem Wettlauf um
Satelliten interessiert ist. Dabei geht
es um etwas, das Satelliten in eine
niedrige Erdumlaufbahn bringen und
nahezu konstant Sonnenlicht erhalten
kann. Dadurch könnte potenziell bis zu
achtmal mehr Solarenergie erzeugt
werden als vergleichbare Systeme auf
der Erde. Die langfristige Vision
dafür ist ziemlich verrückt, denn
Google glaubt, dass es irgendwann eine
ganze Konstellation von Satelliten mit
TPUs haben könnte, die alle
miteinander verbunden sind und riesige
KI-Workloads im Orbit verarbeiten. Aber
es ist natürlich wahnsinnig schwierig,
ein KI-Rechenzentrum in den Weltraum zu
bringen. Erstens muss die Hardware den
Start selbst überstehen. Laut Google
kann eine einzelne Komponente Kräften
von etwa 50 bis 100 G ausgesetzt sein.
Daher haben sie diese Satelliten
buchstäblich geschüttelt, um einen
Raketenstart zu simulieren. Dann ist da
noch die Strahlung. Google hat seine
Trillium-TPUs mit Protonenstrahlung
bestrahlt, während sie aktiv
KI-Workloads ausführten. Und die
ersten Ergebnisse zeigten, dass diese
mehr Strahlung aushalten können, als
man während einer fünfjährigen
Mission im Weltraum erwarten würde.
Eines der größten Probleme ist jedoch
tatsächlich die Kühlung. Im Vakuum
des Weltraums gibt es keine
Luftzirkulation. Daher kann man diese
Chips nicht wie in einem normalen
Rechenzentrum kühlen. Google
experimentiert daher mit Heatpipes und
Radiatoren, um die Wärme von den TPUs
wegzuleiten und ein Überhitzen zu
verhindern. Und dann kommt
wahrscheinlich der verrückteste Teil,
nämlich die Verbindung all dieser
Satelliten miteinander. Zukünftige
Satelliten des Project Sun Catcher
könnten jeweils Dutzende von TPUs
tragen und über Laserverbindungen mit
extrem hoher Bandbreite mit
benachbarten Satelliten kommunizieren.
An dieser Stelle beschreibt Google die
erforderliche Präzision als im Grunde
genommen den Versuch, ein münzgroßes
Ziel aus kilometerweiter Entfernung zu
treffen, während sich beide Objekte
bewegen. Und das ist kein Konzept für
die ferne Zukunft. Google bereitet sich
darauf vor, seine ersten TPUs in die
Umlaufbahn zu bringen, und für 2027
sind zwei Satelliten geplant, um diese
Verbindungstechnologie mit hoher
Bandbreite zu testen. Wir betreten also
wirklich eine Welt, die an
Science-Fiction erinnert, in der diese
Satelliten KI-Workloads im Weltraum
ausführen werden. Das wird uns auf der
Erde unterstützen. Als Nächstes folgt
eine ziemlich seltsame Ankündigung von
Anthropic, die mir persönlich
überhaupt nicht gefällt. Anthropic
sagt nämlich, dass es Nutzern wieder
Gebühren für bestimmte Anfragen
berechnen wird, die seine
Schutzmaßnahmen blockieren, bevor
Claude überhaupt antwortet. Dies gilt
nur für drei Kategorien: Biologie,
Destillationsangriffe und die
Entwicklung großer
Grenzsprachenmodelle. Anthropic gibt an
, dass dies teilweise auf koordinierte
Angriffe auf seine Systeme in den
letzten Wochen zurückzuführen ist.
Fairerweise muss man sagen, dass
Anthropic behauptet, dass 99,7%der
Konten in seinen jüngsten Tests nie
auf eine dieser neuen kostenpflichtigen
Sperren gestoßen sind, und die
Klassifikatoren sollen so eingestellt
sein, dass sie weniger als 0,1%
Falsch-Positiv-Raten aufweisen. Apropos
Opus 5.5: Ich habe einen wirklich
nützlichen Tipp gefunden, den ich euch
mitteilen wollte und der euch definitiv
eine Menge Token und Geld sparen wird.
Einige Tests haben ergeben, dass Opus
5.5 bei geringem Argumentationsaufwand
im Grunde genommen genauso gut
abschneidet wie Max bei der
Aufgabenerledigung, dabei aber etwa 12-
mal weniger kostet. Für die meisten
alltäglichen Aufgaben musst du Opus
5.5 wahrscheinlich nicht bis zum
Maximum an Argumentationsniveau
hochfahren. Du kannst standardmäßig
mit einer niedrigen Argumentationsstufe
beginnen und diese nur dann erhöhen,
wenn du es mit wirklich schwierigen
Problemen zu tun hast. Das ist
natürlich selbsterklärend. Für
einfache Aufgaben stellst du die Stufe
„Niedrig“ und für komplexere
Aufgaben die Stufe „Maximal“.
Manchmal vergisst man das aber einfach.
Eine Erinnerung ist daher eine gute
Möglichkeit, einige dieser Tipps
tatsächlich in die Tat umzusetzen.
Eine weitere wirklich coole und
hilfreiche Sache ist, dass du, wenn du
dein normales Claude-Coderatenlimit
erreicht hast, versuchen kannst, „low
priority“ auszuführen. Dies ist ein
Befehl, mit dem du Claude auch nach
Erreichen deiner Limits weiter
verwenden kannst. Deine Anfrage wird
jedoch langsamer ausgeführt und das
auch nur, wenn Anthropic über freie
Kapazitäten verfügt. Wenn du also
ständig an die Claude-Limits stößt,
solltest du dies unbedingt im
Hinterkopf behalten. Ich werde unten in
der Beschreibung einen Link zu diesem
Beitrag hinterlassen. Das war's aber
auch schon mit dem heutigen Video. In
der Welt der KI tut sich noch viel mehr
. Ich empfehle euch daher dringend,
einen Blick auf unsere Schul-Community
zu werfen, um auf dem Laufenden zu
bleiben. Schaut euch unbedingt die
Fünf-Punkte-Plattform und den
Benchmark zur Welt der KI an. Werft
auch einen Blick auf das Universum der
KI, unseren zweiten Kanal, abonniert
den Newsletter, werdet Teil des
Discord-Kanals und folgt mir auf
Twitter. Abonniert unbedingt unseren
Kanal, aktiviert die
Benachrichtigungsglocke, gebt diesem
Video ein „Gefällt mir“ und schaut
euch bitte auch unsere vorherigen
Videos an, um über die aktuellsten
KI-News auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben.
In diesem Sinne wünsche ich euch einen
wunderschönen Tag, verbreitet
Positivität und ich sehe euch ganz
bald wieder. Tschüss Leute.